what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel all things mcu
and other universes as well such as the
sony spider-man universe dc and star
wars sometimes as well but happy venom
day since venom comes out tonight for
some people i know some other parts
around the world have to wait a week or
two unfortunately but for those who are
seeing it tonight be sure to let me know
what you think about it on social media
or in the comments down below genuinely
curious to see what people think about
this film i'll talk about venom more
tomorrow but today we're going to be
talking about spider-man and that second
trailer now we have heard that that
second trailer for spider-man could be
coming in november and that makes a lot
of sense and i'll talk about that but
we're also hearing other rumors about
what to expect from the trailer
primarily talking about toby mcguire and
andrew garfield so of course we have to
talk about that but there's actually a
pretty big topic surrounding the
trailers that we're going to receive and
the one that we already have received
that is important to discuss primarily
what is real about the trailers and what
isn't what's a misdirect from marvel and
sony in these trailers and what is it
that we're actually seeing that is going
to be in the movie in a way this really
feels like avengers infinity war and
avengers end game infinity war primarily
edited people in or edited people out of
scenes and avengers in game essentially
did the same and it looks like there are
some pretty similar things happening
here with the spiderman no way home
trailer which isn't that big of a
surprise at this point but we'll talk
about all of that in this video and if
you're new and you want to stay up to
date on the mcu be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos so
the first thing that we have to talk
about is coming from the twitter account
big screen leaks and these guys have
been issued in multiple different
platforms multiple different media
outlets magazines so pretty great track
record so far and the other day they had
something pretty big to say about that
second spider-man no way home trailer
according to big screen leaks toby
mcguire and andrew garfield are going to
show up in the final shot of the very
next official full trailer for
spider-man no way home now let's talk
about this for a second because i think
there's a lot of merit to this before
the first trailer came out i was told
some details about the trailer and they
pretty much happened in the trailer now
from the same people and i fortunately
can't say my source or they would get
fired but the source did tell me that in
the latter half of marketing for
spider-man no way home is when they were
going to be showing toby maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man so originally
i went into the first trailer not
expecting to see anybody but tom hall
and spider-man i actually didn't think
they would show us so much of the
multiverse i didn't think they'd show us
doc ock or a pumpkin bomb or lightning
bolts from electro i didn't think they
would show us any of that but they did
and it got everybody super super excited
to the point that the trailer broke
records it beat avengers in game which
had the current record and i'll tell you
exactly why the next trailer is going to
be even bigger but first and a big thank
you to filmora for sponsoring today's
video i know a lot of people have asked
me about what types of software do they
need to use to start a youtube channel
and if you're looking for video editing
software filmora is for you for those of
you who don't want to dish out that
money for adobe premiere this is an
excellent alternative and it's easy to
use it's helped out our cosmic wonder
team a lot of course editing those
spider-man videos that everybody knows
and loves and what's really cool about
filmora is you can do a lot of creative
things easily for example their new ai
portrait feature you can use this to add
a cloning effect which is really really
popular right now you can also use it to
put some insanely cool effects in your
videos and on the people in your videos
and they have things like ar stickers
which are super fun and super easy to
use if you are looking for a easy to use
video editing software that's creative
and fun filmora is for you and right now
you can download it for free by clicking
the link in the description down below
once you click the link it'll take you
to the download site where you can
download it for free for mac or if you
have windows you can click on go to
windows version and then click try it
free for your free version so now of
course everybody is talking about if
they show toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man in the
trailer of course that trailer will beat
any record out there which
coincidentally the trailer that they
would have to beat is their own and
according to big screen leaks this is
going to happen and i do think that it
lines up with what i was told before
originally i didn't think that toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man would make an appearance in
the second trailer i thought there would
be a third trailer in which they would
get shown however if the second trailer
doesn't come until november which that's
the rumored date right now that would
mean that the official trailer for
spider-man knowing home would only come
out a month before the actual movie
comes out so i would consider that the
latter half of marketing for the film
which is when i was told the other two
spider-man would appear so this could
very well be what is about to happen
because if you think about it the
marketing for sony's films and you can
see it happen right now with venom let
there be carnage and it happened with
spider-man far from home with sony when
they get really really close to
releasing a movie they put out tv spots
like every day whether it's a 15 second
clip 30 second clip 45 second clip
they're always showing a little bit of
new footage before the movie actually
comes out right before the movie comes
out and marvel studios does this too i
remember for far from home it was
literally like a new trailer whether
that was a tv spot or like a full minute
plus trailer they were doing those like
every other day and if you recall back
to avengers in-game that's what they did
as well so originally i thought that
maybe the other spider-man would be
revealed in some type of a tv spot but
that's just not gonna happen yes they're
gonna be in tv spots but only after
they're revealed in a big trailer the
reveal of three spider-man in one movie
is going to be a historic event which is
why i actually originally thought they
wouldn't actually show it in trailers
but now i've changed my mind i think
they have to show them in trailers i
think in order to get that hype up and
confirm that they are in the movie to
the rest of the world to the people who
aren't watching this stuff every day
like we are and digging for leaks i
think they have to confirm hey this is a
spider-verse film you're gonna see all
three spider-man i think they have to do
that and i think we might only get one
more official trailer the full link
trailer that tells us more about the
plot where they reveal the entire
sinister six to us and they reveal the
other two spider-man and according to
big screen leaks it's going to be in the
final shot of the trailer which makes a
lot of sense now of course remember that
this is not confirmed and should be
taken as a rumor big screen leaks does
have a great track record and i have
heard some things myself but until it
happens it's not confirmed although i do
believe that we have a pretty good
chance of everything i just said
happening but be aware of one more thing
just because we only see the two other
spider-man in one scene in the final
trailer doesn't mean that they actually
aren't in other parts of the movie in
fact a lot of people actually believe
that we have already discovered some of
marvel's clever editing in the first
teaser trailer things like peter parker
are peter parker tom holland's peter
parker which it's actually kind of funny
that we've gotten to the point that i
have to specify which peter parker i'm
talking about but tom holland's peter
parker has been spotted in the trailer
wearing what toby maguire's peter parker
wore in one of the spider-man films so
the big question here was is this
actually tom holland's peter parker or
could it actually be toby maguire's
peter parker but it's edited so we don't
know that he's in the film yet there are
also some other scenes where peter
parker is wearing his iron spider suit
in a part of the film that actually
looks to be kind of towards the latter
half of the film when he's on the bridge
where we see the pumpkin bomb now we've
learned enough about the film at this
point to know that peter parker is going
to be getting not one but two new suits
and one is an integrated suit and one
does appear to look like it's some type
of an iron spider but not his original
one and in this scene we see his
original iron spider suit come out right
before the dark oxy this is mostly fake
as well this most likely isn't his iron
spider suit in the actual film but a new
suit or some people have speculated that
this could actually just be toby maguire
spider-man because doc ock says hello
peter and he doesn't really know tom
holland's spider-man and tom hall and
spider-man was not dressed in his
spider-man suit instead he was actually
dressed in those clothes that looked
like the clothes toby maguire spider-man
was wearing so in this scene after doc
ock says hello peter and then peter gets
the iron spider suit nanotech go all
over his body that could actually be a
huge misdirect and this could actually
be toby maguire spider-man lately people
have been speculating more and more that
the trailer is going to be pretty
deceiving including
brandondavisofcomicbook.com he briefly
mentioned this topic on twitter stating
that things are most likely not exactly
as they seem so a lot of people out
there are really starting to think the
same thing because this is just what
marvel studios does fortunately we only
have about three months left until we
see the official film and if all goes
according to plan and what the leaks
right now in the rumors say we only have
about two months until we get the final
official trailer hopefully given us that
big three spider-man reveal but let me
know what you think about all of this in
the comments down below and if you've
spotted a scene that you think is
altered or edited or fake in some way
shape or form be sure to comment that in
the comments down below be sure to like
this video and be sure to follow me on
instagram and twitter if you want live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
[Music]
[Music]
you